there is no question life is weird
everything about it can feel kind of
insane at times the way people act the
way the world works or doesn't the
amount of stress we put ourselves
through the amount of seemingly
meaningless stuff we make ourselves do
essentially we're all weirdly self-aware
animals evolved out of some unknown
source of life doing a bunch of random
stuff that we accept as normal on a
planet that we are stuck to you in the
universe we know essentially nothing
about the concept of life as we know it
is just as much science fiction as any
science fiction film or book ever made
in a lot of ways the strangeness and
complexity of life can be overwhelming
and depressing the fact that we can't
understand or be in control of
everything the fact that there could be
misfortune uncertainty and just plain
weirdness all of this can make us feel
confused and small like we are nothing
more than clueless insignificant beings
strung along by life in its absurdity
with no clear direction or purpose but
what separates someone who is able to
still lead a happy positive life in
spite of all this mayhem of existing
from someone who cannot it's how one
deals with the notion of life's
weirdness what separates a positive
meaningful existence from a negative
empty one as predicated by what angle
you are looking at life from the side
that finds anguish in the fact that we
barely understand anything about the
life we live or the side that finds
fascination and intrigue in the mystery
the side that finds spite and anger and
the fact that we cannot control or
predict things in the future or the side
that finds excitement in the fact that
we can't always be certain of what's to
come
the side that finds contempt in the
weirdest of nature and humanity or the
side that finds humor at all we can view
live from one of these two sides the
positive or the negative sure things
aren't always roses and sometimes stuff
is just negative by nature but we can
choose which side we want to build our
home on the side that gets the Sun or
the side that's always in the shade
every day we can choose to try to make
the most of things and revert back to
the positive side as often as possible
we can choose to remind ourselves that
life is so weird and so insane and we
are lucky enough to get the privilege of
being able to experience observe and
explore it whether it is a work day at a
job we don't like a lazy day at home or
we don't feel productive or a day that
we had to sacrifice to some
time-consuming task no day is ever truly
wasted or lived in vain so long as even
if just for a moment
to acknowledge and appreciate the insane
perplexing weird profound and
fascinating life we get to be a part of
and likewise even if a day is filled
with money Fame and achievement no day
is ever truly a success without doing
the same no matter who you are or what
you did today any day that you remember
to acknowledge life in all of its
weirdness from a place of positivity is
a success and today is not over thank
you for watching if you found enjoyment
and value in this video please give it a
thumbs up share your thoughts in the
comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder